well that's the first time an
exterminator said he's gonna pray for us
that's okay right that's not a bad sign
no
what you're doing gene i'm making an
instrument out of spoons and a napkin
holder and dreams and magic obviously
tina how's the burger bob it's okay i
put an egg on it why is dad making a
burger at 8 a.m is he on british time
he's making it to bring to mr dowling at
the bank we have a meeting this morning
and we're going to ask for an extension
on a loan payment oh fun then we really
really need to get that extension all
the restaurant equipment is wrapped up
in that loan so you're giving him a
burger well i mean we can't give him
money tina cause we don't have any
pretty much how about you playing some
of this
what to scare him no to enchant him bob
you know i love this bring him a burger
idea but isn't it a little early to be
making it i mean our appointment isn't
for a while this is a practice burger
why are you whispering i don't want it
to hear him feel bad okay wait um what
nothing what you're great
that feels nice i know i know
[Music]